esta es radio canadá internacional
bienvenidos a canadá en las américas
café también llamada el castor
cibernético una emisión producida por la
sección en español de la radio pública
canadiense radio canadá internacional
difundimos en directo cada viernes a las
doce y cuarto por internet
esta emisión también se encuentra
disponible en nuestro sitio en internet
heresi net punto o sea les invitamos a
contactarnos con sus comentarios
críticas y sugerencias nuestro correo
electrónico es amlat arroba r6 net punto
sea y para nuestros amigos que prefieren
enviarnos una carta a nuestro correo
regulares radio canadá internacional
apartado postal 6000 montreal canadá el
código postal h 3 6 3 a 8 hoy les
acompañan en los micrófonos
leonora chapman paulo gomes barrio leona
régimen o quienes a la roja valencia y
hoy tenemos como invitado al look sima
director de la diversidad y relaciones
con la ciudadanía en el difusor público
nacional radio canadá looks y mar
bienvenido a radio canal internacional
encantado grupo
sabemos que no tienes mucho tiempo vamos
a empezar básicamente con el mandato
radio canadá está comprometida en
reflejar la diversidad canadiense en su
programación es importante que todos los
canadienses se reconozcan a sí mismos en
el contenido difundido y que las
propuestas de contenido en todas las
plataformas encarnen la evolución de la
realidad canadiense ese es el mandato
que está escrito justamente la página en
de radio canadá cuál es la situación
bueno ya depende de qué nivel estamos
hablando o no porque podemos ver esa esa
cuestión a nivel de personal llegamos de
los que trabajan en radio canadá como
todos ustedes como como yo mismo y
también a nivel de los programas de lo
que difundimos al aire y que la gente
voy a emigrar por escuchar a nivel
interno digamos a nivel del personal
estamos progresando bastante rápido
porque lo que queremos
internamente es reflejar también el
mismo tipo de reflejo de que estabas
hablando y reflejar la composición
digamos de la sociedad por lo general y
diría yo y la sociedad en particular
aquí en montreal porque aquí hacemos la
mayoría de los programas entonces y para
ir un poco rápido en los últimos meses y
la dirección de radio canadá ha ordenado
a todos los responsables los directores
generales en particular que son los
principales mandados de radio canadá de
emplear cuando emplean cuando abren un
puesto y emplean a alguien que sea un
cuarto de los nuevos empleados que sea
de la diversidad 14 23% para hacer más
exacto eso es algo muy importante
y tienen esa obligación y van a hacer
ver luego un acuerdo
eso es la parte interna y hay los
programas que claro pues es otra cosa
hacemos programas por el web lo que
estamos haciendo ahora programas de
televisión programas de radio y ahí
también tenemos esa obligación de
reflejar la sociedad que servimos radio
creada es una radio pública que difunde
en el segundo país más grande en el
mundo y va dos lenguas oficiales un país
de raíz de verde orígenes de inmigrantes
ahora cómo se combina este mandato con
por ejemplo la situación financiera del
sector público donde por un lado hubo
recortes brutales que todavía no está
muy claro el panorama y por otro lado el
mandato de tener que integrar a libertad
la diversidad en la programación en el
aire en las emisiones al público como
dentro del funcionamiento mismo de la
empresa
y el efecto principal que han habido los
recortes de presupuesto en los últimos
años
no sé si no parado pues hemos tenido que
ir más despacio o sea que no empleamos
al ritmo que quisiéramos digamos a
nuevos empleados ha habido muchos de los
colegas y lo saben más que tuve aquí en
la jornada internacional que han tenido
que irse de la organización de la
sociedad radio canadá entonces y la
evolución de personas es más despacito
digamos que quisiéramos pero andamos en
esa dirección a pesar de los problemas
de presupuesto que siguen hasta cierto
nivel o sea que todo el mundo sabe que
el presupuesto de la educación no es a
nivel de otros países desarrollados en
europa servicios públicos tienen mucho
más por habitante que nosotros entonces
hacemos con lo que tenemos y con ese
objetivo
que es más que un objetivo es una
obligación de emplear a más de 20 el 23
por ciento de nuevos empleos
venidos de la diversidad es lo que vamos
a hacer vamos a ir despacio pero
seguramente para nuestros amigos en
facebook quizá esto que estamos hablando
es la cocina interna y para que la gente
que está viendo el programa siguiendo el
programa ya hacia afuera hacia inclusive
la imagen de canadá al mundo cuál es la
importancia porque es necesario mostrar
esta diversidad
porque esa diversidad es es canadá o sea
esa diversidad es la imagen que canadá
tiene es no solamente la imagen es la
realidad de este país es un país de
inmigración lo hemos dicho
y esa inmigración que están presentes
digamos y solamente hay que montreal la
mitad de la población tiene un un padre
y un padre o madre que querían ir afuera
quien en el otro país es enorme enuncia
que hay muy pocos países en el mundo muy
pocas ciudades grandes como montreal
donde se donde sucede entonces tenemos
esa obligación es la imagen es la
naturaleza de canadá y tenemos que
alcanzar la digamos es una organización
que bueno ya tiene cierta existencia a
cierta edad a la cercana tiene 81 años y
ya entonces ha sido el espacio en el
pasado
estamos en este momento seguramente
acelerando el ritmo de diversificación
de la empresa sí me parece importante es
la primera vez que tengo conocimiento de
que radio canadá impuso esta cuota de 23
por ciento para contratar a trabajadores
provenientes de la diversidad me hace
acordar a un poco el tema de las mujeres
en política que está demostrado que
desde el momento en que se hace
obligatorio una cierta cuota las mujeres
tienen más posibilidades de presentarse
a cargos políticos ahora dicho esto me
gustaría saber lo que kate y cuál es
cuál es esta realidad a nivel de la
parte inglesa de radio canadá si vice a
veces tengo la impresión cuando veo la
televisión o escucho los programas que
hay una mayor diversidad que se da en en
la red inglesa de radio canadá es cierto
que la población también es mucho más
grande pero es que está tal vez un poco
más avanzado en este tema civis yo me
equivoco
y de esa forma la mente te estás
equivocando un poco no está bien mejor
que por qué porque si hacemos la
comparación y el objetivo la meta de
nuestros gallegas ingleses hay mucho más
alta y porque es mucho más alta y porque
la sociedad en particular de toronto es
mucho más diversificada que la sociedad
de montreal hay un pero mundial y la
segunda es la segunda pero hay un nivel
bastante alto de vancouver de serie la
segunda no hemos de ver a la tercera
entonces hay un nivel de diversidad
importante hay que moderar lo he dicho
pero en toronto
a nivel de minoridad de minoridad es
visibles en particular es mucho más
entonces si miramos digamos el nivel de
de alcanza miento de los colegas
ingleses en relación con la diversidad
de la sociedad de toronto sucede más que
nosotros un poco mejor pero no tanto no
tanto y a veces aquí material vemos que
los colegas ingleses de recibirse hacen
bastante bien porque aquí el monte
una guía que inglesa es muy
diversificada entonces plural fijan aquí
en los programas locales de montreal
pero si miramos a los programas
nacionales as hechos desde toronto bueno
sucede mejor que era yo quedan mejor que
la parte francesa pero no tanto
y que para digamos para para que
nuestros escucha veedores que están del
otro lado de la cámara tengan una idea
más clara cuando hablamos de un 23 por
ciento quizás para ello sea un poco
abstracto porque no tienen todas las
cifras pero cuál es el número total de
empleados de la de la sociedad radio
canadá para tener una idea de cuántos
empleados cuánto sería el 23 por ciento
y yo le diría somos más o menos digamos
a nivel de la sociedad se ve ese radio
canadá ingleses y franceses más o menos
7.100 mitad y mitad digamos 3500
franceses 3500 ingleses y digamos la
composición de personal se enoja y
bastante despacio digan más o menos como
500 500 nuevos empleados al año bueno
entonces para llegar a 1700 hay todavía
bastante camino que recorrer hay que hay
hay que irse hay muchos años adelante
seguro no se va a ser mañana yo estuve
en el programa anterior por qué
con el programa francés y hay un dato
que me pareció súper importante porque
está esta tarea que se impone radio
canadá no es solamente para los
empleados de la sociedad sino para la
producción hacia el exterior lo que ve
la gente en la televisión en lo que
escucha en la radio también va a tener
una necesidad de cumplir una cuota de
visibilidad de esta de esta granja de la
gente de acá exacto sí ahora y no me
gustaría que el cuento un poquito de qué
se trata esta nueva política y
seguramente es lo más visible para la
gente que nos escuchan en este momento
los programas lo que la razón por cual
es todo por la cual todos nosotros
estamos aquí no para hacer por ganas
entonces a nivel de la televisión puede
hablar de la televisión porque la
televisión todavía tiene un impacto más
grande bastante grande diría y en la
televisión lo que hay que saber es que
la mayoría de los programas son hechos
por productores independientes los
productores que no son empleados
como nosotros son gente del exterior son
productores privados como decimos ellos
hacen todas las todos los programas de
variedades todos los programas de
telenovelas son hechos afuera de
reeducar nosotros contratamos a esa
gente para hacer programas que ponemos
al aire ahora lo que hay nuevo desde
diciembre el mes pasado tenemos una
cláusula una obligación cada esos
productores independientes de poner
adelante un plan de inclusión de la
diversidad lo que no existía antes antes
les decíamos que tienen que hacer los
mejores esfuerzos para reflejar la
diversidad que existe ahora tenemos una
obligación una obligación detallada no
solamente a nivel de lo que ponen al
aire qué tipo de animador qué tipo de
actores en en la telenovela sino los
contenidos los contenidos y el tema
digamos de los problemas pero también
quién hace los programas los productores
la gente de responsabilidad digamos
dentro de la producción autores y gente
que no se ven al aire entonces es es un
paso adelante muy significativo y yo que
eso que vamos a ver una diferencia
próxima tiene que dejarnos en 12 minutos
más antes de que te vayas lo que
podríamos y quizá también explicar a
nuestros nuestros oyentes que se
entiende por diversidad porque es no
solamente el color de la piel origen
pero también está inclusive la
diversidad auditiva los acentos que es
un tema muy muy en boga y también la
cuestión de las las opiniones las
perspectivas y todo eso pues podría ser
google contenido de otro programa porque
la cuestión de los acentos es muy
importantes cuando hablamos de
diversidad hablamos de la diversidad por
lo general pero más específicamente
estamos hablando de minoridad es
visibles de los autóctonos y de la gente
con
antich a eso entonces y también entraría
se incluye porque son
un grado bastante alto
el programa azul digámoslo que radio
canadá y si vice están haciendo desde
hace un tiempo y que me parte
se hace un tiempo
creo que hay esfuerzos muy grandes para
darles lugar hoy en día y programas
específicos con los físicos con las
primeras naciones donde la palabra la
tienen los autóctonos como dicen lo que
si todavía yo creo que falta radio
canadá es decir al radio canadá es decir
hay una expertise una experiencia hay es
ciudadanos provenientes por ejemplo de
américa latina que son expertos
científicos y mo para decir y que no se
los ve todavía como invitados a los
programas incluso de información de
radio canal así estamos dando
información se dice formación a los
periodistas
tendríamos que hablar más de su efecto
pero más interesante es que si sólo para
despedir en de lo que quería señalar un
dato curioso que en este momento ahora
tú eres la diversidad y entonces quieras
invitado para otra programa con más
tiempo con mucho gusto perfecto muchas
gracias lo que hay un avión ese ese es
nuestro nuestro color de trabajo es
responsable también en radio canadiense
sobre la diversidad a lux y marc quien
ha estado con nosotros dando algunas de
los programas las iniciativas en el
difusor público para justamente
representar mejor la diversidad y
objetivo desde que de cada 100 empleados
20 y 33 sean eso me parece importante a
la hora actual al aire son solamente
cuatro sea igual a mí me parece más
importante lo que hablaba por eso le
pregunté con respecto a las producciones
porque es la necesidad de ver esa
diversidad en los programas que nosotros
vemos porque uno ve la televisión
canadiense ya no se ve refleja una
encuesta que acaba de salir los de esta
encuesta donde dicen que una parte
importante del
canadienses no se ven reflejados de sal
de un medio y lo que él hablaba también
es que este tipo de cosas impulsa este
cambio que está impulsando con esta
nueva necesidad de poner gente tanto a
la interna como en las producciones
también va a producir un cambio en la
industria porque los mismos productores
que hacen los programas para radio
canadá los hacen para las otras
productoras los otros canales
entonces si hacen una que vienen de la
diversidad no van a sacar esos
profesionales para poner otros para
hacer otra producción van a usar el
mismo recurso humano y eso quiere decir
que próximamente que también comentaba
en el programa anterior que estas
producciones las producciones de
variedades probablemente sí pero las
producciones de novelas y ese tipo de
cosas vio que se está impulsando ahora
se va a ver en la televisión
probablemente en producto interesante y
si no me equivoco sólo para darle datos
a nuestros oyente aquí que hablaba
específicamente de la realidad de
toronto si no me equivoco
rufo el 51% de los habitantes de las
hicieron afuera y claramente es decir es
una realidad que es completamente un
poco diferente a la de montreal o
incluso la de vancouver no quería
agregar que en lo que respecta a la
diversidad al contenido y todo esto
tenemos a nuestra colega paloma martínez
que está trabajando justamente con lux y
marc en ese aspecto y bueno vamos a ver
cuál va a ser el resultado de todo esto
ya que bueno tenemos personas
interesadas que están justamente
trabajando en pos de lograr un cierto
equilibrio pero hay que reconocer
también que en una sala como ésta donde
hay tantas viejas estructuras maduras
mentales pues exacto toma tiempo
tiempo y va a tomar tiempo lograr un
cierto equilibrio igual hablaban de
maspalomas que también estuvo el
programa pasado hablaba de esto que pasa
hoy en día por ejemplo ella está
formando gente en los productores
puntualmente los los investigadores de
los programas
de noticias para contactar gente que
viene
digamos de la inmigración entre comidas
y la historia es que a veces esa gente
no se siente tan segura entonces dice
bueno te contesto una semana y en una
semana ya no es importante no contar
pero hay mucha y dice sí pero el
problema es por ahí cuando es en hacer
entrar a esa gente al circuito de la
información para que yo hablaba más de
invitados especiales como por ejemplo
científicos no que existen que están y
que siempre están dispuestos a hablar
ahora tu planteo es un poco diferente y
en cierta medida va tan bien con con
algo que se discutió hace dos o tres
años una información que salió que decía
por ejemplo uno se preguntaba qué pasa
que no hay periodistas acá que nacidos o
que nacieron acá pero que provienen de
otros países de la diversidad y que no
vienen al radio canadá y hubo una
encuesta o algo sobre eso que decía que
los estudiantes mismos inmigrantes
no se sentían capacita pensaban que el
radio canadá es una institución con
tanta historia que no habría lugar para
ellos eso es lo que un poco para poesía
se planteó en el que vos es decir el
otro lado de la moneda y la nueva moneda
es la aproximación participar que
necesariamente no se siente
la cabeza de esa persona acto exacto
exacto tiene que ver con las
limitaciones que uno mismo se pone
entonces bueno ahí hay un trabajo
importante y creo que es radio canadá
con esto está dando un paso adelante
pero lo tiene que hacerlo para para que
la población quebequense también pues
diga este es esta es mi red es nuestra
canción es nuestra casa para agregar a
lo que estás diciendo en la misma en el
mismo orden de ideas eleonora es
justamente el trabajo que está haciendo
paloma es de tratar de que los distintos
programas inviten además es exacto que
inviten a y científicos etcétera que
vengan a desde otras nacionalidades y
que puedan estar con sus acentos y con
sus perspectivas diferentes y además
pues creo que eso es una riqueza muy
grande que está esperando ahí no
manifestarse si están este programa
escala de las américas café también
llamado el castor cibernético al jazz
a mi conocido como 'el castor' cybernet
bien entonces vamos a ir brevemente a
algunas algunas cartas antes de entrar a
los temas porque hemos vivido bastante
correr vamos a tratar de ponernos al día
a leonora acá hay un comentario sobre el
tema de batalla de generaciones en la
armada canadiense triunfan los jóvenes y
el wi-fi escribe javier gonzález
nungaray y dice de acuerdo a la
investigación que realizó la marina
canadiense se establece que las nuevas
generaciones es decir los jóvenes
canadienses le hacían el feo a
reclutarse en la marina por el simple
hecho de no actualizarse
tecnológicamente bueno hay que ajustarse
a la modernidad tecnológica saludos
cordiales espero que la hayan pasado
bien en navidad y feliz año nuevo
muchísimas gracias a javier gonzález
nunca harán que esta siempre fiel con
los oasis aquí se está viendo nuevos por
ese entonces un saludo pablo si rojo
tengo acá una nota de la historia del
baile y la rueda de casino salsa que fue
una entrevista que hice hace mucho
tiempo con un par de una pareja cubana
que estuvo de visita aquí en montreal
dando una serie de conferencias asesor y
casino en el casino era una institución
en cuba ya donde comenzó la música donde
se bailaba a la gente iba en la gente en
la habana iban al casino salsa para
bailar y se reunían allí hay tocaban las
grandes orquestas como la sonora
matancera y otras entonces ellos
esta esta pareja hacía un recuento de la
historia de la salsa de como la salsa
nació de alguna forma porque algunos
pensaban ellos afirmaban en ese momento
que la salsa venía de nueva york
entonces ellos decían es falso la salsa
no viene de nueva york
exacto
la salsa existía en cuba y en particular
en ese lugar en el casino salsa donde se
viven las parejas a bailar y todo esto
entonces pero es que el comentario que
está acá es lo que no entiendo él dice
dónde puedo inscribir me escogió con
comic-con y coca dice dónde puedo
inscribirme tengo una fractura de hueso
y necesitó una operación acción urgente
[Risas]
simplemente eso
es curioso en realidad antes quería
responder
justamente a nuestro amigo javier
gonzález en un cara que me mandó un mail
para preguntar por qué hacía una semana
que no recibía el el sirma el cyber
magazine y hubo un problema en la
máquina que enviaba el cyber magazine a
principios del 2018
hace un par de semanas está solucionado
debería empezar a funcionar como
corregido que hubo otros correos también
está 37 suponemos que un poquito de
paciencia yo me fijé y está funcionando
ahora así que supongo que volver a la
normalidad en el transcurso de estos
días como habrán notado nuestros amigos
esto es en 2018
comienza con cambios hemos cambiado el
día de la emisión de programas de jueves
a viernes
este programa estará ya al aire hoy el
sábado y el domingo y por otro lado
tendrá una duración más
será más corta grama y también la
tecnología está cambiando porque vamos a
estamos incorporando más más a
plataformas más plataformas en la red en
internet
si esa plataforma es bueno en realidad
estamos nosotros siempre hacemos el
programa a partir de facebook live y
empezamos con youtube la semana pasada
estamos recorriendo hay un par de
cositas para que salga lo mejor posible
y estamos también haciendo los test que
prontamente se verán en nuestro sitio
directamente también a la hora del
programa si ustedes entran al sitio de
radio canadá en español va en la porción
donde está el carrusel con todos los
reportajes eso se desplaza hacia abajo y
va a aparecer la pantalla con la emisión
también bien en ese momento aquí tenemos
algunos mensajes en nuestra página
facebook que gladys caleyo dice
felicitaciones leonardo miguel rovira
hola amigos es el programa no se puede
ver con algunos de la emisora en directo
dice que no puede venir esto por la web
danielle camporini saludos desde mar del
plata en un día espectacular
verdades
gladys cabello nuevamente explica
felicitar a yurena abril dice me doy
cuenta que es más fácil entender
vuestras conversaciones cuando os
escucho en vivo una fiel oyente de cape
lee que va a hablar español muy bien a
fines de 2018 es de acción nuestra
oyente de cap de nuevo brawn su ex y así
que un saludo allá pues si hay nuevos
que saboreamos la mejor sopa de mariscos
y mariscos y bueno quiero agregar rojo
que no solamente fue javier gonzález
nungaray el que tuvo dificultad para
recibir el boletín hay acá también otra
otra otra oyente mariel que nos dice
hola no recibí el boletín de r6 desde el
sábado pasado que pasa gracias entonces
no sé nuestro querido cuenta está
supuestamente está reestablecido yo
estos últimos dos o tres días lo recibí
un poquito estoy abonado
para justamente para ver nuestras
informaciones y de paso chequear si
funciona el sistema como corresponde y
estaba arreglado ahora no sé la gente
está afuera me gustaría el número
notifique se identifiquen para ver en
seguir haciendo un seguimiento de cerca
bien vamos ahora a pasar a los temas que
recomendamos a nuestros oyentes para el
trabajo realizado a lo largo de la
semana por el equipo de radio canadá
internacional en español
leonora tú has ha abordado el tema de
las condiciones de vida o condiciones de
vivienda para los trabajadores
temporales extranjeros este es un tema
que viene desde hace un tiempo ya y que
fue denunciado estas condiciones de
vivienda para los trabajadores
temporales sobre todo en el área de la
agricultura que vienen a trabajar a
canadá organismos diversos que
justamente defienden a estos
trabajadores denunciaban las condiciones
por ejemplo decían que vivían algunos en
hacinamiento son lugares donde era para
cuatro personas para dormir no dormían
ocho entre otras cosas falta de agua
potable en fin ahora la situación no es
la misma en todo el país hay sobre todo
se decía está invitados que cuando se
trata de granjas con más chicas que
grandes industriales las condiciones son
mucho mejores tienen mucho más cuidado y
el tema nuevo acá es que el gobierno
desde canadá ha decidido establecer
nuevos estándares de vivienda para estos
trabajadores temporales extranjeros
entonces invite al programa
arteaga que es un experto en este tema
en el cual él explica cuáles son estas
nuevas medidas que el gobierno
canadiense ahora está exigiendo y que es
algo que entró en vigor el primero de
enero ya está y lo que él dice que las
los consulados aquí en canadá ya están
avisando a todas las granjas y las
grandes industriales de este país que
contratan a trabajadores temporales para
que pongan en condiciones estas
viviendas
sopena de que si no cumplen el gobierno
karim se les va a retirar la posibilidad
de contratar a estos trabajadores
temporales entonces está bien parece
seriamente el gobierno decidido a
proporcionar estos cambios y también de
arteaga pues da otros otros elementos
sobre qué es lo que está haciendo el
gobierno canadiense para mejorar estas
condiciones no cada año gran como 40 mil
a 60 mil trabajadores temporales vienen
para cosechar esos miles y eso está
creciendo cada vez más por más porque la
población canadiense pues está
envejeciendo o se está retirando y se
dice que si esto no se hace con
trabajadores inmigrantes pues
es probable que la frutilla tu mesa
todos los veranos
rufo entonces queramos y los tomates
tampoco entonces de ahí es la
importancia de acoger los y acoger los
como corresponde claro de que se
respeten los derechos como en cualquier
otro lugar del mundo de estos
trabajadores a una vivienda digna a la
salud que este es otro tema en el cual
el gobierno canadiense según el experto
tendría que también implicarse entonces
el tema pues está para los que quieran
en ir sola el envejecimiento de la
población canadiense eleonora sino que
está también que el trabajo en el campo
es un trabajo duro ese trabajo de
cosechas de frutas y vegetales
entonces no todo el mundo lo quiere
hacer y por eso hay una escasez de mano
de obra que el gobierno canadiense llena
haciendo venir trabajadores en general
de centroamérica y hacer ese trabajo
allá en sus países de la cav y las
críticas indican que en lugar de traer
trabajadores temporales con condiciones
muy limitadas que deberían dejarlos
venir como inmigrantes con sus familias
que una vez o tal vez una vez que llegan
como trabajadores
a las que se les permita iniciar los
trámites para quedarse en el país la
iluminación pablo nos da cuenta que esta
semana se nombró un defensor de el
canadiense para la empresa responsable
exacto así mismo ese es el título que le
da el gobierno defensor canadiense para
la empresa responsable ese es otro tema
que también hemos abordado a menudo aquí
en radio canadá internacional hemos casi
todos entrevistados a defensores de los
derechos humanos que vienen de
centroamérica y sudamérica a denunciar
las violaciones de los derechos humanos
el daño al medio ambiente que produce la
industria sobre todo la industria
extractiva minera sobre todo de canadá
en en esos países pues bien desde este
miércoles pasado
el gobierno canadiense sorprendió
nombrando este cargo de defensor de los
derechos humanos que es una primicia
histórica o sea no existe el cargo de
defensor de los derechos humanos en
otros lugares tampoco entonces pues
canadá está dando un paso hacia adelante
y esa noticia era vino a dar el ministro
de comercio internacional françois
filipe champaña quien todavía no se ha
nombrado esta el proceso se hace anunció
la creación del cargo pero no todavía no
hay un nombre para que se va a abrir una
licitación se va a abrir el cargo y va a
haber va a haber una selección ahora
bien dos instituciones han trabajado
desde hace tiempo en que se realice ese
proyecto y son la red canadiense de
rendición de cuentas de las empresas y
el consejo canadiense de cooperación
internacional estas dos organizaciones
que trabajan con los organismos de
cooperación internacional y de ayuda
internacional
han estado pues trillando con el
gobierno para que se creara justamente
ese empleo y finalmente se hizo este
miércoles y yo tuve la oportunidad de
conversar con julia sánchez que es la
presidenta y directora general del
centro canadiense para la cooperación
internacional el cese y bueno pues
pudimos hablar de la evolución de ese
proceso hasta la hasta hasta el este
este anuncio hecho por el gobierno
canadiense y ella pues nos explica todo
como como ha sido llegar hasta ese
anuncio bien gracias pablo es esta esta
entrevista está de nuestro sitio
internet eres en el punto o sea
finalmente leonardo tú nos das cuenta de
los cambios en facebook así ese facebook
que a partir del 2018 su creador y su
director no de mark zuckerberg avisó que
quería hacer cambios importantes para
ayudar a los usuarios a interactuar
mejor porque que se estaba perdiendo la
esencia d
facebook que es justamente era el hecho
de reagrupar esa comunidad de gente y
que se está bueno desvirtuando con el
tema de información que hay muchísimas
publicidades que aún no lo empujan a
decir me gusta me gusta me gusta los
rusos los rusos entre otras cosas
entonces se propuso hacer una serie de
cambios y va a ser un cambio bastante
visible dentro de un par de semanas
suponemos donde cambiará la organización
y la estructura de la página en general
para que las noticias que era un poco
más relegadas y que la interacción entre
las comunidades ya constituidas dentro
de la red social puedan compartir mejor
sus inquietudes y las noticias en
realidad no queda en realidad del todo
sino que si alguien trae una noticia
para discutir se puede discutir pero que
no la preponderancia sea la noticia sino
que sea la interacción entre los
usuarios y eso estaba relacionado con
estas fake new también es ahí el tema de
centralidad criticado sobre todo en
realidad otra aplicación y también es
parte de estos cambios es poner un
control mucho más importante con
respecto al hace años pero lo que él
dice es que se está perdiendo la esencia
de lo que se había pensado o por lo
menos de cómo había sido constituidos
principalmente facebook y era para
reunir a la gente y que la gente está
mucho más alejada por el tema de las
noticias en realidad entonces lo que va
a hacer que no necesariamente falsas no
no la noticia en general entonces
nosotros como medio por ejemplo
tendremos que compartir las noticias de
otra manera para que la gente pueda
recibirlas igual va a haber un apartado
donde va a estar todas las noticias
todas las noticias
espero que el contenido noticioso no
interfiera en la interacción personal
dentro de la red bien amigos esa es la
oferta de rufo pues y yo bueno en fin
vamos a estirar los minutos lo que les
propongo es justamente una una nota que
hice sobre la desaparición en canadá de
la cadena de tiendas y ers sí y esto
aparte me interesó el tema a partir de
un hecho concreto y es que no sé si es
vuestro caso pablo ha donado pero hay
algo que no me gusta hacer es ir de
compras
yo estoy en el país correcto entonces lo
que generalmente hago es porque no me
divino me incluye a mi rufo porque te
explico por qué por qué curiosidad
porque cuando entras a un centro
comercial la ropa de los hombres que
está en el primer piso cerca a la puerta
de entrada y está seca la caja lo que
claramente yo he hecho algunas veces es
ir vas y compro las tres veces la misma
camisa del pantalón y tres veces de
zapatos y no vuelo más la tienda por
años entonces eso es una gran allen que
para la mayoría mí tampoco me gusta y la
magazine para eso terminaba pero pero
claro es quizá una generalización pero
la forma en que por ejemplo supermercado
están hechos la sección de mujeres
es sin mensaje sin amenazas y que
entonces esta tienda que tiene 60 días
65 años de historia en canadá
fusión de viejas compañías de simpson
ishares finalmente cerró sus puertas a
nivel nacional estuve el pasado 2000
domingo el día en que se traba por
accidente estaba un centro comercial por
el portaba se logra un teléfono pero vi
a la gente que entraba salía y tierra
como era una y aunque era un ambiente de
tristeza porque no hay región en canadá
en donde la tiendas tías no haya tenido
su presencia en el mundo el mundo porque
el link inclusive en bolivia había gente
que preparaba la navidad
bolivia es que lo que hacía el catálogo
y tú escogía es que lo que querías y te
lo hacías
entonces en chicago es una compañía
que empezó con una fusión entre una es
simpsons que era canadiense y si eres
esto empezó en los años 50 y 253
haciendo ventas por catálogo
británica pero al final cerraron porque
finalmente la fuerza de estos gigantes
que son amazon que ahora ya no necesita
ser a la tienda compras por internet
alibaba a otra otro gigante chino esta
vez entonces ese es un cambio de formas
de consumir que también implica un
cambio en la forma en que uno va a base
sus compras entonces de una forma fuera
tecnología pero otro aunque se dice que
esa tecnología sí es cierto pero lo que
pasa es que la compañía si es fue
comprada por un especulador por la
compañía especulador estadounidenses de
fondos de riesgo que en lugar de
invertir
la compañía prefirió pagar 600 millones
de dólares a los accionistas y dejar que
el animal vieja y dejar que llegarán la
gente sin empleo 12.000 empleos
aparecieron entonces es el digamos es el
es el capitalismo especulativo
con respecto a si eres quería mencionar
simplemente que recuerdo de que cuando
yo era niño hace rato un avión si es en
barranquilla y me gustaba ir al cyber en
barranquilla con mi mamá porque no
porque fuéramos de compras y no siempre
el aire funcionaba a viajar había aire
acondicionado 1 y había una escalera
américa
y entonces en la ley de ahí para
refrescarse un poquitico y subir y bajar
por las escaleras eléctricas creado
tengo aquí un comentario en este caso de
miguel rovira y ese leonardo no me deja
ver en directo la emisión desde la
cuerna error exactamente justamente
estamos haciendo los test para qué
mejor es lo estuvimos haciendo la semana
pasada en nuestra nuestra página de
desarrollo hoy lo pusimos en la página
online y hay algo que no funcionó
estamos tratando de corregirlo
esta mañana ni siquiera aparecía la
ventana ahora da para nuestra misión a
pase la ventana pero con un error
suicidio en facebook si en facebook y en
youtube pero la página supuestamente
tiene la capacidad de desplazar el
carrusel y que nuestra misión
había un anuncio en nuestro sitio web
que decía quiere ver el programa haga
clic justamente cuando hace clic
aparecen tan ahí se ve el programa
directamente en el contexto de nuestra
página no está funcionando pero con el
programa chino
y bien amigos aquí concluimos el
programa gracias por estar con nosotros
estuvieron hoy con ustedes soy anna
chapman pablo gómez barrio leonardo
gimeno y quienes al arrojo valencia a
quienes desea un excelente fin de semana
cuídense mucho y pues estaremos aquí te
damos un saludo también nuestros amigos
rusos mexicanos todos los espías
muy ansioso